this video sponsored by loot crate the
monthly subscription service for epic
geek and gamer items and pop-culture
gear more on loot crate at the end of
the video hey wise crack not a pickle
Jared here and today we're breaking down
the season finale of Rick and Morty
season 3 in this season especially Rick
and Morty continues to flop the
meaninglessness of our existence nobody
gets it nothing you think matters
matters this isn't special this is
happening infinite times across infinite
realities every time the show's teased
us with an authentic moments of love or
emotion it's ripped it right out from
under us my grandpa was my hero
your mom wouldn't have accepted me if I
came home without you and your sister so
now you know the real reason I rescued
you I just took over the family Morty
this leaves an interesting challenge for
creating a TV show how do you have
characters grow when there is no meaning
well the show gives us a novel solution
that's a little better than just
spiraling deeper into nihilism guarantee
you're gonna die if you touch me and
there's no afterlife everything just
goes black don't do it and that growth
isn't from the titular protagonist but
the matriarch of the Smith family wasn't
list wise pack quick take on the Richter
Ian Morty day and of course spoilers
ahead okay so first a quick recap Rick
and Morty are called in to help the
president with some x-files shenanigans
but soon four of helping out the leader
of the free world Rick and the president
begin an ever-escalating dick waving
contest the two unleash their vast
Arsenal's against each other before Rick
has a more pressing matter to attend to
Jerry oh damn it the more interesting
subplot however is best fresh off the
events of episode 9 Beth begins to
question whether or not she had taken
Rick's offer to be replaced by a clone
and if she in fact is the club to settle
the matter she seeks the help of Jerry
who recreates one of their first dates
and rekindles their love but still
worried she's gone Blade Runner Beth
runs off to the woods with the family
where Rick shows up to kill Jerry and
convince her that she's not a clone and
our last quick take we talked about Rick
and forming Beth of what her
intelligence actually means am i evil
worse
you're smart when you know nothing
matters the universe is yours and I've
never met a universe that was into it
Rick's answer to all this of course as
know is don't think about it faced with
this Beth has given radical freedom to
choose her destiny and this freedom
brings her solace about her choice to
stay with or leave her family regardless
of which choice she makes I don't know
if I can do it then stay and luxurious
in a life you can finally know you've
chosen my secret bonus is that no matter
what you choose you're finally gonna
chill the [ __ ] out but this episode
seems to suggest that she chose to stay
path you crazy [ __ ] you're my daughter
and as a newfound sense of happiness
she's being a better mother to summer
sort of I just put it on for fun tonight
now I can't buy it oh come on you look
great you're only young once
just promise if the results are too
strong you'll use protection finally
love's Jerry and has brought her family
back together
real family now in many ways things will
be like season 1 but for some it may
seem kind of weird that she suddenly
rekindles her love with the helpless
parasite that is Jerry we could apply
some of the philosophical themes we've
identified an earlier quick takes here
like starts bad faith and radical
freedom alienation versus agency but I'm
gonna propose something a little new to
explain why Beth reconnects with Jerry
and her overall paradigm shift amor fati
the cure for common nihilism now what
really made me think of this is this
moment my memory is of hating that night
but now reliving it all I can feel is
how lucky I am to be loved by such a
simple honest simple man this isn't the
woman you married Jerry Beth worried
she's a clone must now confront and
question her past not only is she still
thinking about Rick's original
proposition the ability to flee her past
but as a possible clone are those
memories even her own and what does that
mean for her future or her happiness
amor fati is a Latin phrase that Freddie
each Meister used that means love of
faith amor fati is the affirmation of
life being what Nietzsche called
a yes Sayer not to be confused with the
pervasive corporate yes-man and it's
tied to a thought experiment many refer
to as eternal recurrence to simplify
imagine a demon shows up and says he's
going to Groundhog Day your whole life
do you get thrown into existential
despair because you have to infinitely
relive questionable life moments like
the popularity of Smash Mouth
frosting your tips in middle school or
do you to paraphrase Nietzsche high-five
the demon and say you've never heard of
anything more divine to want to relive
everything that's happened in your life
for eternity the good the bad and
everything in between is the ultimate
affirmation of life
it's amor fati and it's part of
Nietzsche's grand plan to escape the
crushing nihilism of existence given
Beth's existential crisis and proclivity
for Ric like disillusionment causing
intelligence Beth has to confront her
past I came to you for help and now I'm
insulting your intelligence and look
where intelligence gets you and with
Jeri she gets to relive a small part of
it
I just thought it let's don't sweat and
while she may have hated her life the
first time around
including her date with Jeri this time
around she'll be that Nietzsche and yes
sailor but I don't think Beth is
rewriting the past either she doesn't
deny the years of misery she has endured
amor fati isn't about some kind of
everything is a blessing in disguise but
it's more about not to shun the ugly
aspects of our lives as she tells Jerry
she's no longer the woman he married and
sure Jerry may be an idiot but maybe
simplicity is what a person with a
family history of using intelligence to
justify sickness needs we see another
amor fati s moment when Beth thinks rick
has come to retire her I guess I was her
which makes me related to her but I
don't relate to her she left her family
and me which means I relate to them
brushing aside the Blade Runner rhiness
of it all Beth is also functionally
saying yes a version of Beth may have
chosen to leave but I will embrace being
left with my family rather than dwell on
what could have been and if you let me
extrapolate a bit while there may be
infinite universes where Rick and Beth
have made infinitely different choices
she wants to stay in this one as
Nietzsche says my formula for greatness
is amor fati that one wants nothing to
be different not in the future not in
the past not for all eternity while
Michi didn't necessarily philosophize
about infinite realities he did write
about the impossible task of knowing
oneself I'm out of excuses to not be Who
I am so Who am I what do I do
Beth doesn't know who she
is but desperately wants to for
Nietzsche the logic of why we actually
do anything is impenetrable and if we
want to apply this Nietzsche and framing
to Rick we the fans almost never know
what actually drives him why would you
do that for me no no maybe you matter so
little that I like you maybe it makes
you matter
maybe I love you so while Beth confront
about whether or not she chose to be
cloned or whether or not any of it
matters in the infinite versions of
herself Nietzsche would say it really
doesn't matter all we can do is love our
fate and that seems to be the choice
that Beth is made and to me this is
really interesting because while the
show is often portrayed Rick as a kind
of Nietzschean ubermensch at war with
the meaningless cosmos there is no God
in your face but Rick in a quite unhuman
Chi way doesn't really create his own
new meaning as much as he just kind of
dicks around in the most
self-destructive way possible Beth on
the other hand when faced with the
meaninglessness of the cosmos finds
happiness and that's pretty Berman Chi
if you asked me now if you're like me
and don't know what to do with yourself
now you have to wait probably forever
first season for consider checking out
our wisecrack podcast the squash where
we broke down every episode of season
three over the break we'll be breaking
down older episodes engaging a lot more
with your questions and trying
desperately to interview anyone who
works on the show and thanks to loot
crate for sponsoring this video for less
than 20 bucks a month loot crate sends
you geek and gamer collectibles and
apparel right to your door it's the best
place to go for monthly swag from your
favorite franchises and when you enter
the code wisecrack you'll get 10% off a
new subscription just sayin and the
October loot crate theme is mythical
it's packed full of items from stranger
things Marvel Buffy and ghostbusters so
you won't want to miss out on this crate
so click here or go to the link in the
description to head to loot crate comm
slash wisecrack to nab those exclusive
items from those epic franchises you
have only until the 19th at 9 p.m.
Pacific to sign up and receive this
mythical crate so don't wait thanks loot
crate for sponsoring this video I'm off
to go fill the Rick & Morty void in my
life with some carbs peace guys